Німці прагнуть мати гарний вигляд і вдягатися за останньою модою.
Зиск від цього мають магазини.
Понад 66 мільярдів євро громадяни Німеччини щорічно витрачають на одяг.
У шафі в кожного дорослого в Німеччині у середньому 95 предметів одягу -
і це ще не враховуючи шкарпетки й нижню білизну.
Шопінг вже майже перетворився на хобі.
Згідно з опитуваннями, споживання друге улюблене заняття німців на дозвіллі після садівництва.
Вибір - величезний. Зокрема і в продуктових магазинах.
Щомісяця німецька родина в середньому витрачає 342 євро на їжу та напої.
Однак є проблема:
Лише у Німеччині 18 мільйонів тонн харчів взагалі не опиняються на столі, а викидаються.
Так само і деякі інші покупки відправляють на смітник.
Щороку у Німеччині позбуваються 46 мільйонів тонн відходів
та великогабаритного сміття.
Серед них і текстиль.
Згідно з опитуваннями, майже два мільярди одиниць одягу в Німеччині
використовують лише зрідка чи взагалі не вдягають.
При цьому на виробництво однієї лишень пари джинсів необхідно майже сім тисяч літрів води.
Хіба не марнотратство?